how's it going everybody so as you may
or may not know New York Comic Con is
happening right now
and last night Fox actually showed 14
minutes of Dark Phoenix footage now I'm
not in New York right now I am NOT
attending New York Comic Con so this
does not come directly from me there are
multiple sources multiple channels
multiple companies that were there and
they all reported the same exact thing
because they all saw the footage so I'm
going to give you a summary of what
everybody saw and just a fair warning
there are spoilers for the movie it's
only the beginning of the movie but
nonetheless there are spoilers so the
scene starts off with a Space Shuttle in
space in distress the President of the
United States actually calls the x-man
for help he has an x-men phone inside of
his office so he picks up the phone
calls Professor Xavier and he sends the
x-men into space in the x-jet so the
x-men go into space unsure whether or
not the x-jet will be able to make it
ultimately they do make it and they
arrive to the shuttle
once the x-men arrived to the shuttle we
see each of them use their individual
powers cyclop uses his optic blasts to
help stabilize the shuttle storm freezes
the air that is leaking from the shuttle
and Nightcrawler teleports into the
shuttle they manage to save most of the
astronauts and then they call upon Jean
Grey to hold the ship together with her
telekinesis as she does this a huge
orange energy force approaches the ship
now they don't call it the Phoenix force
but let's face it that's what it is
so this orange energy engulfs the ship
while Jean is holding it together the
ship then explodes and the energy goes
inside of Jean so again they don't call
this the Phoenix force they actually
call it a flare but it's definitely the
Phoenix force so the x-men returned to
Earth as heroes for saving the NASA
astronauts they then return to the
x-mansion where they are greeted with a
round of applause from the mutants there
we then have a scene between mystique
and Professor X they are disagreeing and
arguing and mystique states that
Professor X is just using the x-men to
create the favor of the humans and by
doing so he is putting the x-men and
more
more dangerous situations and Professor
X does not deny it the scene actually
ends on a rather funny note mystique
states that the x-men are usually saved
by the women on the team and that they
should rename the group the ex women so
that's a summary of what a lot of people
reported that they saw in this 14
minutes of footage of Dark Phoenix the
positive thing from all this is that the
people that attended and got to see this
footage actually said that it was all
really good we know that there have been
many reshoots for Dark Phoenix and that
the release date has been pushed back a
couple of times now so hopefully that's
all so they can get this movie right so
that's it for the New York Comic Con
Dark Phoenix footage that was shown
based off what you heard and based off
the trailer that we saw what do you all
think about this upcoming movie let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
also a reminder about the giveaway I'm
doing i'm giving away a few copies of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray or
ant-man and the wasp whichever you would
prefer some special edition posters and
some special memorabilia as well all you
have to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero thank you so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]